[موسيقى]
ولاعبه يسخرون من البرازيل رشفورد في ورطه
بسبب لوحه سيارته يعود للحراسه في الجليد
هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
سخره مدرب ريال مدريد كارلو انشيلوتي من
الاخبار التي ربطته بتدريب منتخب البرازيل
حيث اكد المدرب الايطالي بانه لديه عقد مع
الفريق الاسباني حتى عام 2024 كما ان
لاعبه البرازيليين لا يسالونه عن هذا
الامر بل يمزحون معه حول هذه الشائعات
ويملك ريال مدريد ثلاثه لاعبين برازيليين
في صفوفه وهم رودريغو فينيسيوس جونيور
وايدير ميليتاو
ماركوس راشفورد لا يزال ثور متعب خارج
الملعب وهذه المره بلوحه سيارته راشفورد
وضع لوحه خاطئه على مركبته من نوع
ماكلارين وهو رقم يعود لسياره اخرى وكان
الرقم المميز قد صمم خصيصا لراشفورد قبل
ان تكتشف الجهه المعنيه بان هذه اللوحه
ليست متاحه وتاتي هذه الحادثه بعد ايام من
مخالفه النجم يونايتد بسبب سرعه المفرطه
داخل المدينه والتسجيل السته نقاط سوداء
عليه
نبقى ما اخبار مانشستر يونايتد الذي يعد
من اشهر انديه العالم لذا كان من الطبيعي
ان يهتم الملياردير ايلون ماسك بشراء
النادي الانجليزيه ماسكو بحسب تقارير
اعلاميه فانه يجهز عرضا وقدره باربعه
مليارات دولار و500 مليون لتقديمه قبل يوم
الجمعه المقبل وهو الموعد النهائي المحدد
من قبل عائله جليزر لتقديم عروض شراء
النادي
كشف بيتر شيك حارس تشيلسي السابق واحد
اساطير النادي بانه حقق حلم الطفوله بعد
مشاركته كحارس في مباراه هوكي الجديد
مرتديا الرقم 39 الملك في الامر ان اللقاء
الذي شارك فيه تشيك هو لقاء رسمي وليس ودي
او استعراضي تحت انظار 1200 متفرج كما ان
الحارس لم يتغير كثيرا خاصه وانه ارتدا
خوذه تشبه الى حد ما تلك التي كان يرتديها
اثناء لعبه كره القدم